تفاصيل غريبه في وصيه زوجه دونالد ترامب
السابقه والراحله ناشطون يسخرون من مذكرات
جونسون ويقترحون عناوين لها ضبط طاقه من
طائره في الفلبين بتهمه تهريب البصل
والفواكه هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقولها لكم
من قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
في خبر اثر ضجه واسعه وتحديدا في امريكا
كشفت مجله فورد تفاصيله وصفت بالغريبه
لوصيتي توزيعي زوجه دونالد ترامب السابقه
والراحله ايفانا لتريتها المجله كشفت ان
الثروه ستقسم بين اطفال ايفانا دونال
جونيور وايفانكا والكرام كما تركت عقارين
لاصدقائها مشيره الى ان الراحله حاولت
تركه عقاري اخر لزوجها السابق رصانه
روبيكندي لكنه توفي قبلها بينما لم يحصل
ترامب الذي شارك في تشييعها على شيء من
هذه التركه واضافت همم التقارير بان
المستفيد الاكبر خارج اطفال ترامب قد تكون
دوره كاري التي عملت مع عائلتي لعقود
كمربيه
بعدما وقع رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الاسبق
موريس جونسون عقدا لكتابه مذكراته اثناء
توليه رئاسه الوزراء في بريطانيا سخنا
رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي من العنوان
المحتمل للكتاب ناشطون عبر منصه تويتر
غردوا بعناوين ساخره مقترحين على جونسون
ايطلقها على كتابه ومن بينها هنا تكمن
اكاذيب جونسون وسلسله من احداث العمل
المؤسفه وكانت دار النشر البريطانيه التي
تتولى نشره مذكره جوفا قد اوضحت في بيان
ان جونسون وقع عقدا لكتابه مذكراته مشيره
الى ان الكتابه لا يحمل عنوان بعد لكنها
فتاه الى ان الكتابه سيكون مذكرات لا مثيل
لها لاي رئيس وزراء
في حادثه صادمه هزت المصريين فقدت ام
ابنها على يد والدها وشقيقها التوام بسبب
خلاف عائلي على الميراث الام المخلومه
اوضحت العربيه نت ان والدها وشقيقتها
هاجموا سياره اسرتها اثناء تواجدهم بها
وانهال شقيقها بالات حاده على الزجاج
الخلفي للسياره حيث مقعد ابنها اما والدها
فكان يهاجم زوجها مشيره الى ان السبب هو
خلاف عائلي على ميراث وهو عباره عن قطعه
ارض زراعيه تبلغ قيراطا واحدا فقط اي ما
يعادل 175 متر مربعا فيما بدات السلطات
تحقيقاتها في الحادثه
والى الفلبين هذه المره حيث ضبطت السلطات
افراد طاقه من طائره فلبينيه بتهمه تهريب
البصل والفواكه عبر مطار مانيلا الدولي
السلطات اوضحت انه تم القبض على موظفي
الخطوط الجويه الفلبينيه الذين وصلوا في
رحلتين منفصلتين من دبي ومن الرياض ومعهم
27 كغم من البصل ونحو عشره كغرامات من
الليمون والكيلو جرام من الفراوله والتوت
وكان مسؤول حكوميه فلبيني قال سابقا ان
جلب البصل او اي منتجات زراعيه اخرى في
الامتعه يعد استيرادا حتى بكميات
للاستخدام الشخصيه وفقه تقارير تاكد ان
سعره كيلو البصل في مانيلا اصبح
11$ مؤخرا
وفي خبرنا الاخير انخفض عدد سكان الصين
العام الماضي للمره الاولى منذ عام 1961
وسط توقعات بان تصبح الهند اكبر دوله في
العالم من حيث عدد السكان في عام 2023
المكتب الوطني للاحصاء في الصين اوضح ان
عدد السكان بالبلاد انخفض نهايه العام
2022 بنحو 850,000 شخص مقارنه بالعام 2021
مشيرا الى ان معدل المواليد في العام
الماضي بلغ 6.77 مليون لكل الف شخص
انخفاضا عن معدل مواليد عند 7.50 مولود في
2001 واقل معدل مواليد على الاطلاق في
الصعيد